The war on drugs was crushed on Election
Day, at least as much as you could crush it
in one day. In every state where marijuana
legalization or decriminalization or progressive
ization of drug policy was on the ballot, it won
in Arizona, Montana, New Jersey and South Dakota,
voters legalized recreational marijuana.
Incredible in Mississippi and even South Dakota
voters legalized medical marijuana. South Dakota
had both legalized recreational and legalized
medical. In Oregon, voters decriminalized but not
legalized all drugs, including cocaine and heroin.
Also in Oregon, voters legalized the
use of psilocybin, a psychedelic drug
found in so-called magic mushrooms in
specifically supervised therapeutic uses.
This is huge. Oregon also is. So what's going to
happen in Oregon is you will no longer be punished
with jail or prison time for small amounts of
possession of any drug that includes cocaine
and heroin. If you get caught with cocaine and
heroin, you can either pay a hundred dollars fine
or do a completed health assessment, the details
of which I don't yet know. But we will find out.
In Washington, D.C., voters decriminalized
psychedelic plants also following following
the lead of several other cities. And again,
Oregon, the first state in the United States
in modern times to decriminalize all drugs.
Marijuana is now legalized in 15 states, plus
Washington, D.C., although Washington, D.C.
still does not allow sales, all measures won
by at least five percentage points in every
state. This really is not hugely shocking.
Over the last decade, we've seen polls show
marijuana legalization is increasingly popular
in many polls. Even among Republicans, there is
support for at least marijuana decriminalization.
This is a big rejection of the war on drugs.
It starts to signal a major shift in U.S. drug
policy. It's going to push for more of the
disassembly of the war on drugs. But another
thing that's important to remember is we are
getting the first steps here, but we still need
to deal with the criminal justice component.
So, for example, if anybody has a record now
for in Oregon, if you have a record for possession
of small amounts of cocaine, which now are legal,
decriminalized, I should say, not legalize
decriminalized, what happens to your record?
It should probably be expunged. And that is the
next step. That is the next step here. That's
the next forefront. Legal cannabis. You know, nice
for people looking to go to a nice store and get,
you know, curated, curated pot. But the criminal
justice piece is more difficult and it has to
come right after this. And hopefully we will
see that. Also, I expect to see the tobacco
industry get more and more into cannabis.
And there's also real opportunities in
terms of taking the tax revenue that this will
generate and really doing great things with it.
We're going to be discussing it more. We're
going to be looking to places like Colorado,
even Massachusetts, as potential models of how
this can be managed, how the money can be used.
But a major win against the war on drugs
on Tuesday. And we'll keep talking about
ballot initiatives because there's a lot
of really interesting stuff to discuss.